do i believe i lost my career to the
rest of them yes i do
that must be a terrible feeling
horrible um
yeah
horrible
because you're you know you're still a
young man
so to be looking at your age at a lost
career
must be very upsetting yeah
horrible but you know what maybe
maybe what was written for me was this
and maybe that's just what it was a
massive believer everything happened for
a reason
and
like i said hopefully in five years time
um
we're gonna see a big change um and i
can look back at it
that um
i did something that is far bigger than
any runs i've got or any wickets i've
got but yeah it's horrible it hurts
well i hope you're right i know
i hope that your testimony today
will be part of delivering that change
and finally
you've mentioned your your wife uh lots
of times and then amongst all your
travails it seems clear you've got a
very strong
partnership with her
um i just and that that of course is the
bedrock of lots of people's happy lives
i just want to ask you how she
has coped with us and how she is now
coping with all that you as a family
have had to endure
um struggled
and still continues to
over the last 15 months it's been we've
got two young kids
one's just over two and one's about to
come turn one
and they've not had a dad really because
all i've been worried about is
yorkshire
going out to discredit me um and now i'm
gonna deal with it and
dealing with lawyers dealing with
prayers um
so yeah challenging but i just hope
today provides some sort of closure and
uh
i can treat her for what she deserves
thank you